When I decided to do this,...
...I first talked to my wife who is sitting here in the audience.
And she had married a relatively stable, goofy...
...but still relatively stable person working at a Wall Street firm.
I worked at a quantitative hedge fund and this was a hard decision.
And I was looking for the right framework...
...in which to make that kind of important decision.
And the right framework I found is a Regret Minimization Framework.
And that's just a nerdy way of saying that you wanna project yourself to age 80,...
...and then think back over your life and if you're 80,...
...you wanna minimize the number of regrets you have throughout that period of time.
I think this is something a lot of people do maybe subconsciously, they probably...
...very few people probably name it Regret Minimization Framework...
...because most people are healthier than that.
But it was a very clear way for me to think about making that kind of life decision.
And the way it helped was I thought, okay, if I go do this thing...
...and participate in this thing called the Internet...
...that I genuinely believe is gonna be a big deal.
And if I fail, am I gonna regret having tried and failed?
I knew the answer to that was no.